hey Dom it's very nice to meet you and
where are you right now where are you
calling us I'm in I'm calling from
adisama by
the capital of Ethiopia
Ethiopia um you should come have you
your English is uh seems perfect have
you spent any time in the United States
uh yes I I went to college in Upstate
New York oh you're kidding where'd you
go to college I mean I grew up here I I
went to Hamilton College oh okay in
Clinton New York so you grew up in uh in
Ethiopia you did some college in the
United States uh and then you moved back
and what are you up to these days I have
a business with my friend uh we make
fragrances and scented candles and wow
fun stuff like that wow how did you how
did you learn to do this I mean don't
you need to know a lot to make
fragrances
um yes I'm very smart
I'm I'm sure you are but I'm wondering
did you have to study anything in
particular do you have to study
chemistry or do you have to yeah I did I
studied biochemistry
um so it helps a little bit but I mean I
had to like learn a lot of it on my own
on too I imagine yeah it's a lot of
trial and error where you try and make a
Cent and
um and it can go terribly wrong I bet
right oh yeah well some of the the
ingredients for perfumes like they don't
really smell that good so yeah if you
use a lot of something then yeah can be
terrible let me ask you professional uh
opinion as you know in the United States
and across the world
um sometimes celebrities have their own
scent that they Market
um do you think I could have could there
be a Conan scent a a perfume just take
it easy could there or should there well
listen I think we're rushing this a
little bit first let's begin
um uh Adam do you do you think that I'm
the kind of person who could have a
scent out on the market I mean why not
yeah no okay you could have sent maybe
like
um like pumpkin spice
I love it it doesn't matter where I talk
to someone in the world this is someone
in Ethiopia who's
dissing me uh and and doing it very well
no no it's very it's very funny everyone
here uh around me loves you now because
you treated me the way I should be
treated uh and um yeah pumpkin spice I'm
not sure that's gonna be I want
something uh you know manly you know
sexy something that the women are gonna
go do you remind me of Conan O'Brien in
that sexy way pumpkin Vice
for Naughty evenings it's pumpkin Vice
wow so you making sense uh candles do
you do you make perfumes just uh do you
make sense for men or is it all mostly
for women
um we may take both we make for men and
for women but I mean we make a lot more
for women than men is there a favorite
uh way that men like to smell that
you've noticed is there a certain
fragrance that they
um gravitate towards I I think people in
general like any familiar
like if they smell
scent and it reminds them with like
another
they've liked or liked or things right
usually like gravitate towards I would
like because I believe I want my uh
scent to be something that's familiar to
me so that would be frying ham
I want it to smell that's sexy like
frying ham because that's that's what I
grew up smelling
um and it's a very it reminds me of a of
a fascinating time in my life hey I got
news for you buddy that's what you smell
like hey mission of accomplished
it's a very hard it's basically just
bacon grease that's all it is so Adam do
you have a shop is this all done over
the Internet these sales how do you how
do you uh sell your products
um we started online but now we have a
shop where is your shop is it in is it
in the capital yeah yeah
okay it's in a mall so you go to every
day you do you visit the shop every day
in the mall I try to yeah but it's it's
a new mall so like um there's very
little foot traffic right now so we're
hoping for like a a good turnout I'm
sure in the next coming months I'm
confident maybe I could get over to
Ethiopia and do some kind of personal
appearance how would that go over uh
Adam if you said uh Conan O'Brien will
be appearing at the mall in Addis
Ethiopia would there be much excitement
or would there be I don't know I think
so
but I think I mean I think so I know I
know a few people know you here
um
it's gonna be Beetle Mania you know I'm
worried about I'm worried about just if
based on that alone I'm just worried
about people's Safety and Security yeah
I mean people know how many like
okay again you're getting way ahead of
things here gordly I mean I just worry
that with a few people you could get as
many of seven seven or eight people
might show up and then what if pushing
and shoving starts there's no way to
control a crowd like that yeah yeah
laughs